to have a chance to qualify a loss and  he's out six seconds now he's he's toast  here look at his face as well he knows  it he knows it D7 is just curtains  absolute heartbreaking we've been saying  the whole day is he gonna Rue that early  draw when you're slightly better and you  can press against a much weaker opponent  to get rid of resigns he's out  gutting over  final moments and each Geary is knocked  out of the aim chess rapid read it takes  the final spot in the quarterfinals  oh look at the niche this must be  devastating for him he uh played some  draws yesterday  that affected this result he is knocked  out  he must be so disappointed right now  looking at this  yeah taking a look at the game he is  knocked out of the aim chess rap